bonjour et bienvenue sur notre cas télé
dans votre émission vivre ensemble
aujourd'hui nous allons parler nature et
espaces naturels sensibles à l'occasion
de la fête de la nature avec moi sur le
plateau sandrine jillson du département
sylvaine harnes et robert joue un de
l'association allons prendre y aurait en
main bonjour à vous alors vous vous êtes
peut-être déjà promené à la pointe au
sel au dimitile ou sur le chemin des
anglais
et bien sachez que ces sites sont des
espaces naturels sensibles du
département
madame j 7 expliquez-nous ce qu'est un
espace naturel sensible un espace
naturel sensible aux ems c'est un site
sur lequel on met en oeuvre des
opérations pour les protéger donc ce
sont des sites qui sont menacés à la
base soit par la pollution soit par
l'urbanisation et sur lesquels le
département a décidé de mettre en place
des mesures de protection et de
valorisation pour l'ouvrir au public
alors quel est l'intérêt de préserver un
site naturel
l'intérêt c'est de conserver ce
des sites j'aime bien la notion de
patrimoine plutôt qu espace naturel
puisque au moins du coup on se rend
compte que c'est
c'est un bien qui nous appartient et
qu'on doit valoriser comme on s'occupe
de sa maison entretient sa maison son
jardin
c'est important de d'entretenir son
patrimoine naturel et à la réunion on a
un patrimoine naturel exceptionnel
donc c'est important de le maintenir en
bon état
combien de sites sont concernés dans
l'île la plupart des décide des forêts
des espaces naturels sur lesquels on se
promène sont gérés par le département au
titre des espaces naturels sensibles
moi j'aime bien dire que neuf fois sur
dix quand on est en forêt on est sur un
domaine s même arme vous intervenez sur
le site de dioré espaces naturels
sensibles également
expliquez-nous votre mission nous
qu'effectivement je suis animatrice
environnement sein d'associations
prendre néanmoins
l'association est présidée par madame
diallo
nous comptons une centaine de membres et
moi donc je suis animatrice
environnement donc j'interviens au
quotidien sur le site
dans le volet accueil et animation alors
l'association allons prendre y aurait en
main et gestionnaire du site du ray et
caniza donc l'association et
gestionnaires donc ça s'est un temps on
fait de l'animation de la
sensibilisation et on intervient aussi
sur le site dans monsieur robert va
l'aborder
ce volet là en tant que valorisation du
site aménagements
restauration écologique voilà même s'ils
sonnent préciser nous le rôle d'un
gestionnaire un peu plus en fait le
département à chaque fois sur sur les
sites essaie d'identifier une structure
qui est compétente en matière de gestion
des espaces naturels acquis et on va
demander de préserver c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure c'est important de
préserver préserver ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire maintenir le la forêt où
l'espace en état naturel donc lutter
contre les espèces invasives sûr ouverts
en parlera mais aussi valoriser pour
l'accueil du public puisque le rôle de
du département dans le cadre de cette
politique espaces naturels sensibles
c'est d'ouvrir au public
on doit mais pas sous cloche on protège
pour ouvrir au public donc ça suppose
qu'il faut faire des aménagements ces
aménagements faut les entretenir et donc
un gestionnaire le rôle d'un
gestionnaire c'est de veiller à ce que
toutes ces actions soient bien mises en
oeuvre sur le site monsieur revers alors
vous vous êtes chef d'equipe à dioré
expliquez-nous 1 quel est votre rôle
je suis monsieur robert chef d'equipe
sur le site de dioré valeurs appartenant
à la sociologue guillaume n'y a qu'à ma
mission sur le lycée de dante à tenir de
verbois heureusement aménagements
sentiers entretien cos établi du même
peut-être foyer aussi une replantation
il fait parfois pour des espèces
envahissantes c'est mon rôle de ligne
des dvd
d'accord vous avez du monde pour vous
aider pour faire ça vous imaginez deux
d'accord deux personnes qui sont
l'insertion est ce qu'ils sont en
contrat d'insertion à l'idée d'accords
dans mon rôle premier chat du rabin
avait su dans le monde du travail oui
mais à l'emploi rue dur valises à voter
vue je suis le fils
enfin apprendre que ce que je vaux
respecter ou pas parce que c'est par le
travail que bon oui je suis n'importe
quel citoyen propre voulait fermer
quelque chose on a beaucoup de choses
arrive plus uni voulait redonner une
formation en même temps pourquoi une
formation doit donc éviter de d'éliminer
sont pour beaucoup mais pourquoi
jacques tu es d'appareils tranquillement
son programme dans le cadre des contrats
monsieur va le préciser mais les
employés ont une partie formation donc
out terme de leur contrat ils ont
ils passent ils vont en formation est
souvent il décroche un titre par exemple
d'ouvriers de paysage en a même qui ont
eu le permis qu'à ses saints dans le
cadre des chantiers d'insertion donc
donc vous contribuer à la valorisation
du site et en même temps à la formation
de wels personnes c'est formidable
donc vous êtes deux passionnés de nature
c'est justement le thème de la fête la
nature de cette année madame johnson
parlez nous de cet événement auquel le
département participe régulièrement oui
oui le département participe alors c'est
une manifestation nationale de partout
en france la fête de la nature est
organisée ça fait dix ans que le
département y participent donc le
principe en fait de la fête de la nature
c'est de mettre en lumière ce qu'est la
nature la biodiversité de découvrir les
espaces naturels et c'est au tour c'est
une manifestation qui est qui vise aussi
à célébrer la journée internationale de
la biodiversité qui se tient le 22 mai à
la réunion comme on a une période de
vacances scolaires on avance un petit
peu
la période par rapport à la métropole un
fémur mais c'est toujours la même
finalité de découverte de
sensibilisation et du coup le
département comme on est responsable de
la gestion de comme je le disais tout à
l'heure de neuf forêt sur 10 on est un
petit peu le chef de file de cette
manifestation c'est à dire que on
organisait un pilote on fédère tous nos
gestionnaires mais qui participent à la
manifestation et qui propose des visites
guidées gratuites sur les cinq jours de
la fête de la nature alors pour le
département c'est l'occasion de
valoriser ces espaces naturels sensibles
est ce que le public répond présent à
cette manifestation
oui est de plus en plus je disais c'est
une manifestation qu'on a commencé à
organiser il ya dix ans et on voit bien
que la fréquentation est de plus en plus
importante et on a même des demandes de
et je pense que c'est pareil auprès de
nos gestionnaires en parler on a même
des demandes qui sont bien avant
l'organisation de la manifestation les
gens réclament ça va être quand c'est
quoi la thématique vous allez proposer
quoi donc il ya un vrai rendez-vous qui
est pris avec les raisons
vous savez où nous sommes
alors nous sommes sur le s de la forêt
des hauts de montvert donc situé sur la
commune de saint pierre
environ 1600 mètres d'altitude
alors là la particularité de la forêt de
montvert c'est que déjà située dans le
coeur du parc national de la réunion et
et puis c'est un site qui symbolise à
lui tout seul donc le patrimoine inscrit
donc
dans nice qu en fait donc il y à
proximité donc du site un rempart
vertigineux 2000 mètres et puis une
forêt de bois de couleurs qui y perd
bien préservés donc c'est un site qui
symbolise ce bien inscrit au patrimoine
mondial à lui tout seul
donc la forêt de montvert c'est une
forêt de poteaux croire duo une forêt de
brouillard ou une forêt qui est dans la
brume en fait fort et de mao avec
beaucoup donc de deux espèces endémiques
comme le change en le maho
le map ou le fleur jaune et c est la
particularité de cette forêt donc
ces cas le situer donc en grande partie
dans le coeur du parc national de la
réunion
donc c'est la valeur elle est consacrée
en tout cas par ce parc national là une
valeur écologique qui est indéniable 1
et qui a été reconnue de cuisine ce sont
dix en tout cas donc sur secteur
alors les animaux qu'on va retrouver
d'ancrer dans la forêt des hauts de
montvert ce sont principalement des
oiseaux ou des oiseaux endémiques
je veux citer donc le maire le pays le
zozo faire le teltec est une jolie robe
rouge sur la poitrine des mâles
notamment le chaque fois toulouse où la
vierge le zozo blanc dont le principal
aux espèces
alors dans la forêt bois de couleur des
eaux du mana général on va retrouver
donc des marots des plongeons des fleurs
jaunes
pour citer les principales le bois de
laurent martin aussi avec une belle
floraison de cocher retrouve aussi watts
piment donc dans le forez de montvert la
particularité du bois de pin moins c'est
que les fous il ressemble beaucoup au
piment
sauf que c'est pas comme ici
la marne qu'est-ce que vous avez proposé
pendant cette fête de la nature cette
année donc on a deux jours d'animations
dans le cadre de la fête de la nature
donc le 13 et le 14 mai donc le 13 mai
on va proposer de licques de
l'équithérapie donc d'une dérégulation
qui commence à prendre de l'ampleur sur
l'année dont qu il ya une nième petites
associations qui le propose donc c'est
cette association qui va faire
l'équithérapie sur le site
donc c'est faux c'est le public qui va
venir donc on va leur proposer de faire
du soin ont ils vont penser le cheval
ils vont le bruce et y aura des petits
jeux et l'équithérapie
ça permet on s'est prouvé ça permet
c'est très thérapeutique ça permet
d'aider les gens il ya des gens nerveux
ya des gens qui sont malades
ça permet de pouvoir voilà deux est
d'accord monsieur rambert vous vous
allez participer aussi à la fête de la
nature ce qu'elle forme sous forme de
sensibilisation des poulets déchu à qui
lâche trop m'en reparlent ça dans la
nature mais en profite aux radios avec
les visiteurs activités amont faut
respecter ainsi que la neige ou le
protéger je suis vous étaient déjà
préparés tout bon oui vous entretenez
c'est toutes les semaines nous avons
envie qu'on respecte le travail non mon
ouïe ouïe
ben oui c'est normal mais trop de déchet
patrick reine et où d'une sensibilité
battant les gens s'amusent à faire mûrir
mais bon quand même vous les pays
comprend et puis il faut qu'on parle de
la maison avec le temps normalement le
taf loi comprend mieux et c'est ce qui
est important justement de parler de
patrick s'approprie un peu les biens
s'est pas seulement un site qu'on va
voir une fois de temps en temps le
week-end c'est notre patrimoine à tout
ce patrimoine commun qui est d'ailleurs
reconnue patrimoine mondial de
l'humanité donc c'est pas seulement le
patrimoine des réunionnais mais c'est
pour le patrimoine de tous
les habitants de la planète waouh telle
responsabilité
marne à côté de l'équithérapie aura quoi
d'autre comme animation donc après
l'équithérapie je vais prendre le relais
pour pour animer une visite guidée
d'accord donc
ça va partir du deuxième kiosque
jusqu'au point de vue sur sa laisse un
tout le long il y aura des explications
sur les essences endémiques et indigènes
sur les oiseaux protégés donc c'est une
animation on va dire bien complète alors
c'est une manifestation à laquelle vous
participez régulièrement depuis que
l'édition de la fée de la nature il
faisant cela c'est donc on participe
depuis les premières éditions ont votre
public
on a au départ on avait beaucoup de
public extérieur de 2
tout reste très tournée vers mais
maintenant je il ya beaucoup de tourisme
local
comment iranienne dans ce grand mère
donc enfants et donc et aussi beaucoup
d'habitués donc on est tous les en a
deux ou trois familles qui viennent se
pose aussi bien sûr la fête de la nature
que sur les week-ends nature d'accord et
parlons accessibilité est ce que vous
faites un travail en termes
d'accessibilité pour les personnes
handicapées sur le site on va dire que
le site est accessible en partie basse
pour les personnes
formation de handicap parvenir ils
peuvent venir donc le département
d'ailleurs
a mis l'accent sur l'accessibilité du
site pour les personnes en situation de
handicap et
dont tu peuvent en partie basse
participer à l'animation et au delà il
ya deux ans on a fait peu mon aprilia
il ya des jouets l'aide qu'ils les
personnes n'ont pu accéder au site grâce
au jour et l'ept voilà c'est des petits
d'épandeurs donc voilà donc c'est pour
aller un petit peu plus loin un tract
voilà mais sylvain et modeste parce qu'à
chaque mois il ya possibilité enfin que
l'association a possibilité
d'accompagner justement les personnes en
situation de handicap de soi que ce soit
de la déficience mentale ou décider
personnes à mobilité réduite c'est vrai
que l'association s'est s'est fait
partie de nos gestionnaires les plus
actifs justement pour essayer d'ouvrir
les animations les visites guidées ou
personnes porteuses de handicap
c'est important pour le département
puisque c'est un de nos publics
prioritaires voilà inria une réelle
demande de ce public de pouvoir accéder
aux animations
8 nature qui fait
cette année la fête de la nature c'est
du 12 au 16 mai si vous souhaitez
participer à l'une des 52 animations qui
sont proposées sur dix neuf espaces
naturels sensibles
vous pouvez retrouver des informations
sur le site du département 3 wcg 9 7 4
points est faire slash nature ou bien au
02 62 97 59 59
toutes les animations sont gratuits
donc vous l'avez entendu des sites
exceptionnels des visites guidées
gratuit des animations j'espère que nous
avons nous vous avons donné envie de
participer à cette fête de la nature
merci à nos invités d'être venu sur le
plateau et à très bientôt si on a
peut-être qu'à télé pour une autre
émission de vivre ensemble
on